are you ready for the race war I'm not
Tom McDonald is seeing it happening
right now 1.5 million views in its first
weekend trending on top YouTube music
Tom take it
away it's okay to be racist as long as
you hating on the Caucasians teaching
white kids that their Shades the same as
School shooters and rapist maybe I'm
tripping cuz the white children have
been getting taught that they got white
privilege by the white guys and the high
heels who identify as a white women I'm
not proud to be white but I'm fine with
it cuz I'm not allowed to have pride cuz
the colonizers and the white biggest
made white history my business I ain't
never going to give a damn if you like
me I ain't going trip when The
Stereotype me I'm a white boy and a
white boy like me knows that all put
pause there when people talk about
racist they it's just anti-white the
phrase itself is a term of anti-white
racism because they say that you can't
be racist against white people so it is
okay to be racist as long as you uh only
hate white people that's pretty racist
but correct and then he says I'm not
proud to be white but I'm fine with it
we're not allowed to have pride in it
and you know Pride goes Before
Destruction a holy spirit before a fall
but pride is the excessive love of
oneself one is supposed to have a proper
love of oneself and it does raise the
question why can one not be proud in
some way of one's Heritage and when you
dig into the white people broadly you
know are you proud to be an Italian oh
yeah the Italians have a ton of ethnic
Pride now if you'll excuse me I'm going
to ride this rigoton into the sky but
the more Ango the more wasp the kind of
whiter one goes German certainly you're
not allowed to uh then then then you're
not so it's it's very incoherent seems
very halfhazard okay keep going when I
was young they Tau me to never see color
to treat every man as if he was my
brother but now that we're grown up we
hate one another for all other ways so
we struggle and suffer they comeing for
blood we running for cover the
government wants us divided and Dumber
addicted and drunk in the gutter so we
never wake up and never
recover call me culture V cuz I rap good
I don't pop Dan and smoke backwood but
they call me a wigger and label me
Hitler and hate like I'm wearing a clan
Hood it ain't left or right or black or
white is good and evil a folks Hain
normal people united we stand in divid
we fall America we got a get real you
were segregated that was not fair you
were enslaved they did not care but you
were never on a plantation and my
generation was not there that's trauma
in your DNA causing what we see today I
pray to God you staying strong don't
want to see no man in pain be white
folks I'm embarrassed some of y'all are
such caring that prejudice you inherited
was racism from your parents get that
poison out your veins whites and blacks
are all the same they want us in our
Graves just let me try to explain I
swear they want us in a race war dying
every day for
[Music]
go to pause there that's true the lives
obviously do encourage race War I think
there is a way to overstate this though
which is they're saying look if not for
the Liberals constantly cooking up
racial tensions there wouldn't be racial
tensions at all and that's not true
there have always been racial tensions
when you put people from different
ethnic and racial groups together there
is always some kind of tension even take
race out of it for a second when you put
different groups who have any
distinctions together religious
distinctions cultural distinctions any
there there are tensions and so the the
Liberals play on that the Liberals love
inflaming those tensions you know when I
say the Liberals in thaty I'm talking
about the leftist Liberals they love
that but the more right-wing liberals or
the more moderate liberals they ignore
the fact that that's a political problem
at all and they do that to the detriment
of all of us because if you want to live
in a good flourishing political Society
you've got to accept political realities
and if you know that you're going to
have lots of different peoples from lots
of different backgrounds together then
you have to take special care to do the
sorts of things that will mitigate the
natural tensions that exist by the
mixing of peoples one side is is doing
the really evil stuff of making
intentions worse and the other side is
is ignoring the the political issue all
around and what's the consequence of
that the consequence is increasing
Prospect of the race war that Tom's
singing
about
I in the race war our government is paid
for cuz our lives matter more
[Music]
if you born black you lose might as well
go get that you going to die before you
25 get shot over your shoes you going to
get killed by police even when you
follow the rules if you listen to the
news you going to believe all this is
true true I ain't feel no white guil
they don't ride for me when I'm killed I
guess white Li don't mad and sad but
that's the way that I feel I feel like
they feel like like I don't know what
they allall call me sis white male bigot
racist he's a Nazi that's not me I'm not
one of these white commies who think
Black America needs allies in their army
your neighborhoods are G and claim you
Pro black but you fake and guys are
dying on the payement all your hashtags
won't save them that Ain gangster people
begging for their life still I know
white people who can't afford to pay
their life Bill who might feel like they
the ones who losing their life when the
worst thing you could be is not ashamed
to be white white privilege is the
system they position for division if you
black you go to prison if you white your
life is different take some money race
religious sprinkle in some ammunition
and make everyone believe that the other
team is the villain I ain't Pro black I
ain't Pro white I'm Pro American every
color curs of Bones one day when you
bury them whites and blacks are all the
same they want us in our grave just let
me try to explain I swear they want us
in a race war dying every day for whose
lives matter
more I won't be dying in the race for a
government is paid for cuz our lives
matter
[Music]
more they want us in the race war dying
in the streets should be us against them
but it's you against me ain't nobody
going to win everybody going to see that
the color of your skin don't change the
color that you
bleed I swear they want us in a race war
dying every day for whose lives matter
more
W I won't be dying in the race war our
government is paid forz our lives matter
[Music]
more I like the observation which is
that the libs that the ruling class
wants us to be at each other's throats
over race and they obviously stir up
these tensions and it's cynical and it
does give them more power and sure that
that's all true the question that the
song doesn't answer is how are they able
to do that what are the tensions that
the liberal ruling class inflames and
that's the part that I think needs to be
answered and some uh uncharitable people
will say well it's because the races and
different ethnicities and different
groups they're just all so entirely
distinct that they're always going to be
at each other's throats and those kinds
of opinions are going to Fester so long
as nobody is able to actually talk about
the the political reality that anytime
you have distinctions between groups of
people you're going to have to come up
with some political solution to
accommodate those things and to
assimilate the different groups but it's
it's insufficient simply to say well you
know there's only one race the human
race and underneath we're all bleeding
red because at a spiritual level that is
true there is neither Jew nor Greek nor
male nor female but all are one in
Christ Jesus but at the level of
politics in this Fallen World there are
distinctions between groups and there
are hostilities that sometimes develop
from those distinctions and so we've got
to see the political problem and try to
to mitigate those issues or we're going
to end up in the place that Tom says he
doesn't want to go and none of us want
to go all right that's our show I'm
Michael nlls this the Michael nlls show
see you tomorrow burity
SC till you're dizzy you can cancel
everything and everybody in it but it's
not your
America you can burn the flag get
aggressive you can wear a mask and
pretend you're Progressive I got my
first amendment don't for yeah I got the
second it's not your
America